tuesday october 2nd 2018. a journalist
named jamal khashoggi from saudi arabia
enters the saudi embassy in istanbul his
turkish fiance hatije waits outside
jamal shouldn't take too long he's just
picking up a document that will allow
him to get married soon jamal had been
to the embassy before to request the
documents and today all he had to do was
pick up a simple envelope outside the
embassy hatije waits until minutes go by
a few minutes turns into an hour and she
starts getting worried you see jamal
khashoggi wasn't just any ordinary
journalist from saudi arabia he was a
journalist that was a little bit too
critical of the saudi royal family so
critical in fact that he had to flee the
country for fear of his own safety he
wasn't a hundred percent sure that they
were out to get him but just in case
jamal told his fiancee to call a contact
of the turkish presidents if anything
were to go wrong right before he entered
the embassy so there she was waiting
outside the embassy not sure what to do
should she call the number jamal gave
her or was she just overreacting and
that her soon-to-be husband will walk
out of the building smiling any second
now but then two hours go by something
has to be wrong
three hours and the best answer she
could get is that jamal had already left
the way back door obviously that made no
sense three hours turns into four five
six panic sets in hatije had caught
everyone she knows and no one has heard
anything from jamal
ultimately hatije waited outside the
embassy for 10 hours until 11pm at
nights hoping jamal would show up but he
never does the next day the saudi
consulate issues a statement saying that
jamal had disappeared but he definitely
left the building before he disappeared
so where did jamal khashoggi disappear
to had he gotten cold feet and decided
to abandon his fiancee it took months to
uncover the answer and the answer will
make haiti sick to her stomach
jamal khashoggi had once been very close
with the saudi royal family for decades
he reported on saudi politics and even
served as a government advisor but
starting in the mid-2010s something
changed jamal started criticizing the
royal family especially the new crown
prince mohammed bin salman or mbs for
shorts mbs holds absolute power over all
of saudi arabia second only to the king
himself and being critical of the royal
family is a dangerous game to play in
saudi arabia saudi arabia ranks as one
of the worst countries in the world for
freedom of the press
one female journalist nuf abdulaziz was
sent to prison for three years for
reporting on women's rights so in 2017
khashoggi chose not to take any chances
and fled to the us but instead of
keeping a low profile moving to america
the land of free speech and free press
must have embodied him because he kept
writing even more articles online and
for the washington post he kept poking
the bearer
this presented a problem for mbs and the
world family what precedent would this
sets if journalists thought that they
could just criticize the world family
fleece saudi arabia keep criticizing
them and get away with it their subjects
wouldn't take the royal family seriously
anymore something had to be done jamal
khashoggi needed to be used as an
example of what happens if you mess with
one of the richest bloodlines in the
world
september 28 2018 jamal khashoggi visits
the saudi consulate for the first time
to request documents he needs to get
married in turkey everything seems
normal as the consulate official says
that he'll have to come back after the
documents are ready but little did he
know that the consulate has something
else planned for him on his pickup day
on that day several saudi men arrive in
istanbul under private jets and are
driven to the saudi consulates their
assignment bring khashoggi back to saudi
arabia to be punished for his criticism
but somewhere along the lines plans
changed and within minutes of khashoggi
walking into the embassy he was drugged
as he laid their unconscious one of the
saudi men puts it back over his head and
suffocates him from there what happened
was gruesome they proceeded to chop
khashoggi's body into pieces place those
pieces in bags and hand them over to a
turkish contacts we would later find out
from american intelligence that
khashoggi's death had been ordered
directly by muhammad bin salman himself
the crown prince of saudi arabia
the message was clear
no one messes with muhammad bin salmin
or the royal family but that is not
where the story ends because if you
rewind this video you'll notice a common
denominator in almost every article we
quoted
the washington post yes the washington
post was the news organization that
allowed khashoggi to continue slandering
the obviously perfect and noble world
family after he fled saudi arabia and
the post was also the most active on
reporting on his unfortunate death and
they didn't shy away from blaming it on
mbs
so for mbs revenge was far from over now
that he put khashoggi in the ground it
was time to go after the man that
facilitated his criticism none other
than jeff bezos once the richest man in
the world who also happens to be the
owner of the washington post
my name is jake tran i make
documentaries on money power war and
crime with my team subscribe for more if
you want to win a thousand dollars cash
starting right now we're picking a
random instagram follower every single
week to win you just have to be
following me at jaketren just got this
new handle and you're automatically
entered watch out for fake accounts i
will never message you asking for money
and this is pegasus
[Music]
one of the things i love about this
channel is that a lot of you guys are
legit business people with real
businesses and if you've got an
e-commerce business or you're looking to
start one then one of the easiest ways
to save money right now and make your
operation run way smoother is with ship
station today's video sponsor shift
station is the fastest easiest way to
get products to your customers there's a
reason why more than 100 000 ecommerce
merchants use shipstation it is the
fastest most efficient and most
affordable shipping software out there
shipstation is so great that 98 of
companies that use shipstation for a
year keep using shipstation as long as
they're in business it is just that good
shiftstation's easy to use interface
combines order processing inventory
management and customer communication
all together in one place they make your
life easier and cheaper by keeping track
of orders from any sales channel finding
the best shipping carriers and highly
discounted rates that are usually only
available to giant companies they
automate pretty much every shipping task
with just a few clicks you can even
manage orders right from your phone and
it's also available in the uk australia
and canada shipstation makes it easy to
ship anywhere in the world so no matter
how big you get shipstation always has
you covered saving money while making
shipping easier it is a no-brainer start
saving money on shipping today by going
to shipstation.com jake tran for a
60-day free trial that's two months of
easy stress-free shipping for free
that's shipstation.comtran
shipstation make ship happen thanks to
shipstation for sponsoring this video
[Music]
it's january 2020 and jeff and mackenzie
bezos have just announced their divorce
almost immediately after the national
enquirer drops a bombshell the leaked
texts between jeff and lauren sanchez
lauren sanchez is definitely not bezos's
wife
but the questionable text between the
two date back almost a year
long before jeff and his actual wife
split and these texts came from bezos's
personal phone private text no one was
ever supposed to see
jeff bezos had been hacked
we're talking about one of the richest
men on the planet getting breached if
they were able to get their hands on his
personal messages what other sensitive
intel about amazon his family or his
other companies had been hacked he
needed to find out how the breach
happened
so he sent his investigator to the
national enquirer their best answer it
came from lauren sanchez's brother
according to the magazine lauren and her
brother were very close so close that
they often forwarded each other personal
messages from their significant others
an unlikely story but that was the one
the magazine was sticking with but
here's where things get interesting the
magazine was basically falling over
itself to point the finger at lauren's
brother but when jeff's investigators
dug deeper something weird happened
the national enquirer's parent company
ami stepped in and straight up
blackmailed bezos they threatened to
release sensitive images jeff had sent
to lauren if he didn't agree to a few
specific conditions these conditions
were actually an eight-page contract
forcing jeff and his investigator to
publicly state the national enquirer's
story was not instigated dictated or
influenced in any manner by external
forces political or otherwise
they also wanted him to state that the
magazine undertook no electronic
eavesdropping in connection with its
reporting and has no knowledge of such
conduct if he didn't they would publish
the compromising pictures
red flag
unfortunately for the company jeff bezos
wasn't going to go down quietly so
instead of signing the contract he made
it all public on medium
[Music]
as it turns out those texts and the
pictures the national enquirer were
threatening to publish they weren't from
lauren sanchez's brother oh no according
to jeff's investigators they came
directly from the office of none other
than the crown prince of saudi arabia
muhammad bin salman they had hacked jeff
bezos's phone just because he owns the
washington post and mbs was not happy
with its coverage of the hashkaji murder
the saudi arabian prince hated the fact
that jeff bezos a man he knew personally
was pointing the finger at the royal
family for hashkaji's murder
unfortunately for mbs jeff bezos isn't
saudi arabia so they couldn't just lure
him out and chop him into pieces they
had to settle for far less embarrassment
and it worked because mackenzie scott
got a quarter of bezos amazon shares
from the divorce making her the 22nd
richest person in the world at that time
but here's the real question how did mbs
get the compromising texts and images
the leaked pictures and texts all came
directly from bezos's personal iphone x
but jeff bezos is literally one of the
richest men in the world he must have
all the best cyber security so how did
the saudis get into bezos phone and keep
accessing it for months without anyone
ever noticing something was wrong what
sort of program were they using that
could get past the best security in the
world and remain undetected as it
transmits huge amounts of data from
jeff's phone to saudi arabia how did no
one notice a drop in performance or an
increase in data consumption
the answer is pegasus the scariest piece
of spyware known to man
[Music]
[Music]
april 2018 jeff bezos and mohammed bin
salman meet at an event in los angeles
and exchange phone numbers over the next
few months the two send each other a few
friendly messages nothing significant
by may 2018 jamal khashoggi was
regularly writing for the washington
post so the saudis decided it was time
to put the software to work on the
post's owner mbs sends jeff bezos a
video with a program embedded in it that
would later download something called
pegasus 2. pegasus 2 is a very expensive
very advanced piece of spyware from an
israeli company called the nso we all
know not to click on weird links or
download random files from the internet
right
that's how the hackers get you you click
on a link and bam they're in your phone
but what if i told you one of the things
that makes pegasus unique is it doesn't
even need you to click on anything as
long as the government has your phone
number they can have access to your
phone the best way i can put it to you
is that if a government wants you from
an informational point of view once you
get into your phone they have you you
might you know typically you would get a
text and you would open that text and
that would download the little
executable file or you would watch a
video and it would be in the video but
now the newest pegasus systems they
don't even need you to do anything they
can send you a message on what's
happened even if you never even if you
delete it even if you never open it they
can get in your phone it's not your
regular phone hack where you notice
something's off with your operating
system no
pegasus is a smart piece of spyware
spyware on such an advanced level that
unless you know exactly where to look
and when you could never find it and
even if you realize after the fact that
you've been hacked even then there's no
guarantee you could find pegasus that's
because it's built with a self-destruct
option where the guy controlling it can
make it disappear in a second and make
it seem like it was never even there
let's say you were targeted by the
mexican government which happened a lot
to people and
you have it on your phone and you think
you are being monitored in some ways so
you get rid of your phone you turn it
off you put it in the top drawer well
pegasus will say hey this activity has
just stopped self-delete it'll
self-destruct so now you you don't even
have any evidence that it ever happened
even if you could get an fbi involved
and once it's on your phone it can
access everything whatsapp facebook
telegram signal even the most secure
messaging platforms available aren't
safe from the program that's because
pegasus isn't trying to decrypt your
encrypted signal messages after they're
sent instead it's literally accessing
accounts as if it was you using your
phone and that's not all
so they have your phone number they have
access to all your photographs your
messages everything turn on your phone
as a microphone right now in this room
turn on your phone as a camera right now
and even it's so it's so smart let's say
it makes an audio recording of a phone
call and it doesn't download it right
now it waits until the phone is quiet
and it's you know late night in in the
target destination like in your home
it's late night and then it downloads it
at night so that you don't even see a
reduction in performance right and then
people who are sort of watching the the
cost don't see spikes of all kinds of
activity and pegasus does all this by
using a selection of zero day exploits
basically zero day exploits are tiny
bugs left by developers that gives
hackers an opening in this case an
opening into your phone
so by using these zero days or tunnels
past your phone security pegasus can
worm itself into everything on your
phone then it uses that access to
collect everything on you your location
what you're talking about who you're
talking to and what you're doing online
nothing you do on or even near your
phone is private anymore and anyone
anyone in the world could be a target
since its development in 2011 pegasus
has been used by the fbi european
governments and even mexico to bring
down drug lords like el chapo break up a
global child abuse ring and stop
terrorist plots
but with so much power in one little
program the temptation to use pegasus
for other reasons was just too hard to
resist and this is how saudi arabia got
to jeff bezos
[Music]
circumstance did involve mbs who's the
prince of saudi arabia and he did send a
a text with a video
to jeff bezos they knew each other they
had met they had exchanged phone numbers
and embedded in that video was a a
system that
downloaded something that then later
connects to a website and download
something more sinister like pegasus 2
system that
governments around the world use to get
into your phone and then they have full
control of your phone it's designed this
way so that even if the phone is
screened after every unusual message or
attachment there would be nothing to
detect after a while the embedded
program would reach out to a secret
website from which pegasus 2 would be
downloaded once installed saudi arabia
had complete access to and control of
jeff bezos's phone
[Music]
it turns out that it wasn't just jeff
bezos that was hacked by pegasus but
also one of jamal khashoggi's close
associates a guy he worked on activist
projects with jamal's ex-wife's phone
was also accessed by pegasus and almost
immediately after he was murdered his
turkish fiancee khatije had her phone
hacked too which means jamal's phone was
probably hacked too
imagine wielding that kind of power
imagine being able to track someone's
every move through their phone murder
them and then monitor everything their
friends and family say to make sure no
one comes near the truth and even if
they find out the truth you can make
sure they're too scared to ever say a
word about it
that's the reality of the world we're
living in
everyone from the spanish prime minister
to the uk prime minister's employees
have come under attack from the pegasus
spyware no one is safe not the richest
men in the world and especially not
journalists or activists
so what about the rest of us if you have
a phone or any electronic device if you
even come near one you could be watched
you could be followed your secrets your
personal information or naughty text
messages and pictures and search history
every single thing you've done online
could be used against you that is the
world we're living in
with the click of a button
you can bring down
nations to their knees
very rapidly if you so desire
and if you're willing to take the risk
because every system can be hacked
[Music]
the pegasus software was first created
by nso in 2011. around the same time
america was in the middle of the fight
of its life the war on terror and their
main target a guy who refused to use the
internet a cell phone or even connect
satellite tv to his phone that man was
osama bin laden and without spyware like
pegasus it took the us 10 years to track
him down and kill him but you see on
that fateful night when seal team 6
infiltrated his compound in pakistan and
killed the most wanted man in the world
they discovered something drastic
a treasure trove of computers hard
drives notebooks and printed files lying
around on every floor
these files could contain priceless
intelligence and if they left it for the
pakistani military they may never get
their hands on it again
so they asked their commanders for as
much time as they could spare they gave
them an extra 10 minutes
ultimately those 10 minutes became 18
but in that time the seals collected a
treasure trove of 500 000 digital and
physical files a cachet of intel that
would become known as the bin laden
papers
and for years most of those files were
kept classified hidden from the public
but in 2017 the cia finally declassified
over 470 000 of those files for the
world to see and what they contained was
a complete revelation
these files showed a whole new side of
osama bin laden that the world had never
seen before but here's the thing this
video goes deep into bin laden's life
and a video that covers this much detail
on his attacks and plans for the world
is basically guaranteed to get
demonetized which is why we just
released it as a brand new private
documentary available only to members of
this channel the video goes over every
detail of the bin laden papers in all
their infamy and channel members have
been loving this documentary all you
have to do to get access to this
documentary right now and all the other
documentary length videos that are too
controversial to machiavellian too risky
to post publicly is to click the join
button below once you sign up you'll get
exclusive access to the bin lan papers
plus others like every epstein monsanto
the company that owns the world's food
supply mk ultra and many more in the
future these are the things they should
be teaching you in university about how
the world works but unlike university
you get all of this for just five
dollars a month and what's even better
is that if you join and you don't think
it's worth it email me and we'll
personally refund you the money pause
the video and click that join button
below right now
did you know that your security is as
this much non-existent online i did not
before researching this video so this
was a really big eye-opener for me so
let me know what you thought in the
comments below and if you're new here my
name is jake and this is one of the
biggest channels on youtube for
documentaries on money power and crime
so if you enjoyed this one we make
multiple documentaries just like this
one every single week for free so click
the subscribe button below that's going
to wrap it up stay dangerous out there
and i will see you guys in the next one
[Music]
you